you know it was a little bizarre the
other day because i saw that a
figure on the left this entertainer
james corden he hosts one of the late
shows
james corden is overweight he doesn't
doesn't look super healthy
and he came out and he posted a video
and he said you know i'm going to
partner with weight watchers now
which i think has since renamed
themselves i think they're now called ww
because because these new changing
standards say you're not allowed to
criticize being overweight you're not
allowed to suggest
that it's better to be a healthy weight
than an unhealthy weight so they changed
their name and he says anyway i'm gonna
partner with weight watchers because
i feel unhealthy and i want to be
healthier and i felt
it was so refreshing it was so
traditional it was so
sane take a listen i've realized
that every year for the past decade
probably even
15 years on january 1st
i've told myself and anyone that would
listen that this is it this is the year
i'm going on a diet i'm going to lose a
load of weight
i'm fed up with the way i look i'm fed
up with being unhealthy
and this is it this is the year i'm
doing it and because of that
i've over christmas
eaten everything that's in the fridge
because in my head in january
i'm starting this diet and it'll be a
success and as you can see
well it hasn't um
and it started to get me down in a way
that i've just sort of never really been
able to stick
to anything like that and i think i've
just probably spent a long time just
accepting that this is my body and
and that's it but i really am
sick and tired really of
of just doing the same thing every year
totally understandable totally normal
feeling i think a lot of us have felt it
various times you think
i'm just not i'm not feeling good i
should do something to better myself i'm
not perfect the way that i am
none of us is and we can always do
things to maybe improve our lives and
practice some virtues and
exercise sure okay so he says that
therefore i'm going to go start
start up with weight watchers but they
won't use that word
weight or that term weight watchers
because there's a new standard
which says you don't need to be thin
and healthy to be thin and healthy no
actually
these are covers from cosmo magazine
cover says this is healthy and it's an
obviously very overweight woman
who's obviously not healthy 11 women on
why wellness doesn't have to be
one size fits all now
here here i guess is is one of these
tricks posed by
political correctness conservatives want
to be polite if you saw either of these
women on the cover of cosmo
are there these unhealthy women who it
says
this is healthy if you saw either of
them on the street would you walk up to
them and say hey you're
you're unhealthy you're fat you're
unhealthy no nobody would do that that's
impolite we don't want to be impolite
it is the left that is making us say
things that are uncomfortable and might
seem impolite
because they're not merely saying hey be
nice to
people who you know have certain
deficiencies
or people who have certain health
problems or whatever yeah of course no
one needs to tell you that
they're walking up to us and they're
saying hey hey
two plus two equals five right two you
need to say that two plus two equals
five if you don't say the two plus two
equals five
you're a bigot and we look at that and
we say look man i don't care
you know if the lady whatever she's got
her own struggles or whatever
but two plus two does not equal five and
that is not healthy
that that is an inversion of standards
it's what political correctness
always does because the whole
because it is a purely negative movement
and i think the amena women thing
is kind of waking some people up to this
it's a purely
negative movement to overturn everything
we once thought was true to remake the
world
you know john kennedy popularized this
phrase
when he was president and he was
referring to a
socialist playwright george bernard shaw
and he was quoting
shaw and kennedy said some people see
things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say
why not and his brother robert kennedy
then used
this phrase when he was running for
president then after robert kennedy died
ted kennedy quoted it at robert's
funeral
and a lot of left-wing politicians have
quoted this as an inspiration ever since
then
and one of the funny things about
kennedy quoting literature
is that john kennedy liked to quote
literature but he never read literature
so he's always misquoting all these
authors
dante he's misquoting shaw what he said
what he was quoting from shaw is
actually a scene from a play series
called back to methuselah
and that phrase comes from the mouth of
the serpent in the garden of eden
tempting eve
it is the words of the devil even in
shaw is describing the words of the
devil here
and the left is quoting this is some
great thing but
it reminds me of whitaker chambers who
says communism
you know he's an ex-communist and by by
extension i think we could say all sort
of radical leftism
it is the it's not a new ideology it's
the second oldest
alternative faith of mankind that began
in the art
garden when the serpent said ye shall be
his gods
it's trying to construct a fantasy world
whereby this is healthy
whereby amen is who cares about the
etymology of it who cares about what it
means
it means whatever we say it means and
that nasty word men
is in there and we can't have man in
there because men are bad because
according to the new standard
men are bad and we and the future is
female
and there's actually no such thing as
men or women that
is a a totally new code and if we think
that we're going to oppose that kind of
code
with limp laughing and with
these sort of shallow
encomia to libertinism and you do you
and do whatever you want
we're hoping for something that never
was and never will be no society has
ever existed that way
and ours will not either and it's why we
have continued to lose lose lose
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you